i think my husband needs viagra though i
think he just needs some [ __ ] new
choice
right out of you
i thought i had it right now this
function but i know what i just needed
away
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
there's a certain confidence that comes
with being properly brewed there's an
ara a vibe you can just tell by the way
you carry themselves
we call this bge big groomed energy and
there's only one way to get that bje
manscape we'd like to introduce you to
the best and biggest ultimate ig bundle
yet the platinum package 4-0 manscape
is the leader in below the waste
grouping now trust them with the rest
okay you know i had an experienced man
in houston years ago where i tried to
uh manscape myself
with a razor that was not a message
and i nicked myself
but as we know from the o.j simpson
trial even a nick can leave blood
everywhere
join the four million men worldwide who
trust manscape by going to
for mountainscape.com off free shipping
with the code
omghi of course i was wearing white
corduroy pants it looked like as
somebody had dropped a piece of lasagna
on my crotch
[Music]
thanks our sponsor matera
the craft trusted effective and
accessible cbd products that support
deeper sleep relaxation and relief go to
matera and you spell it
m-e-d-t-e-r-r-a-dot-com
o-m-g hi and enter the code omg hi
uh at checkout for 30 off of free
shipping on your first order also listen
you know
most people have to take something to go
to sleep and a lot of the stuff that you
take
is chemical it is it might be even a
pharmaceutical and those things are all
bad you know there's been cases where
you've seen that people have taken a
pharmaceutical and they're driving a
tractor they don't even have a tractor
or there's some place they're not
supposed to be and it's because of the
reaction or the side effect of the
medicine so uh matera is taking all of
that out of it so when wherever you go
to bed you're going to wake up in the
same place when you took matera
hey and i want you to know you spoiled
me george somewhat but
you don't have i don't have beer did i
use too much baby powder
i actually said i got enough baby powder
i get baked cookies brother
but but i i i've got uh let's see if i
can get in front of the camera right
here right here put it in front of your
face otherwise it's getting lost in the
green driver
there you go
all right i don't have no beer so i got
me a bottle of wine right here did you
get it from the [ __ ] uh from the
straight from the bottom taking it
i've got my glass
i'm gonna get all bubbles here's my hey
cheers man to you guys
cheers to you george hey so i can't tell
you where i am
but
it's gone with the wind no um
um
i'm gonna go see uh david gilmore
tonight man uh
the one of the girls that works at
harris says are you a fan of pink floyd
and i'm like
yeah i mean pink floyd to me
i mean first of all first of all those
guys don't get along which is awesome
because they're both [ __ ] great
separate
like they don't get along
it's like if the guys in tierra were
bigger bigger stars the two brothers god
rest her soul oh yeah rudy and steve
i heard i heard uh somebody uh saw
paranormal and the two brothers have
passed on and even in the afterlife they
don't talk to each other
[Laughter]
but i'm gonna go see uh david gilmour
he's doing i guess it's 50 years from
the dark side of the moon
oh really that's awesome years
50 years and it's 50 years since
somebody broke our [ __ ] front window
we never found out who did
two things two anniversaries to
celebrate
there you go
we're all the best pro windows
everybody's outside nobody saw anything
huh
hey i saw you on a cookie show
with uh bert nelly the other day yeah
and i saw you get you talking about uh
your old friend ed yeah she was you know
they were married for a long time and
then you know wolf and uh it's funny man
because you know you never know in life
what's going to happen like i remember
one time i landed
coming from somewhere traveling in
burbank and and i saw eddie and valerie
bernice like in the early 80s and they
were all kind of cuddled just this big
puff of hair you know and right there
trying to lay low both had big hair and
i'm like oh man is that damn i'm gonna
walk in there and i guess eddie told me
that they were going through a fight in
las vegas and
they were trying to lay all although but
they were you know it was early on in
the in the not early on but in maybe
eight mid 80s they had been married
probably like five years and uh they
used to go to the fights together and
i never thought that
i'd know i'd know them both i mean
valerie was big because she's from the
you know tv and then she lived in the
valley went to granada hills we talked
about that and then ed was like you know
my favorite band and and all that
[ __ ] it wasn't until i saw that and i
and i told the wife you know that you
had taken ed down to the show as i'm
watching her show
uh because the wife told me hey george's
gonna be on the cooking show so i i was
watching it
and
she says well yeah they were married i
had no idea they were married oh
everybody forever okay yeah
you know ed man it's like you know
the thing that i mean you know
you know
um
that show reels and i used to i watch
reels you know i watch reels uh that
that channel they would do the those uh
you know uh uh
murderer or
um uh um
the breaking of the band like they did
van halen and break into the band
and then i saw that his son wolf was
upset because they did an
autopsy
show on eddie you know
and that he was really you know like
he's very vocal man like
much eddie was very quiet you know just
never really kind of wanted to get into
things and and wolf is opposite man he's
very i think it's italian maybe the
italian side that you know they both
come out and said you know this is some
[ __ ] because you know
and uh i called the uh
the president of real's channel
and i told him that
um
i thought it was it's just inappropriate
man like you know
you know you don't know look at jimi
hendrix and jeff morrison and janice
joplin and and you know all the 27 club
from the early 70s 1971 maybe that's
maybe that's more fair game
than a guy that has just not even been
gone two years and who who
who
you know
was very ill but then also
was very private man like you know what
uh when you read somebody's autopsy man
that that's that's the private you know
they're not there to defend themselves
and they're it's a very private private
thing and and i just told him that i
just thought it was it was it was a bad
taste and
i've never been able to help anybody
making documentaries or anything like
that they want to talk to some of our
witnesses victim hey it's personal
they've already been through it let it
go
and i don't care who you are bad guy
good guy somebody loves him
and
that's terrible you know what man that's
a good that's crazy you say that huh
good guy bad guy somebody loves him it's
true sure somebody
will say hey
you know just because my son was five
foot and he wore a leather suit and my
[ __ ] doesn't mean he killed those
people up in the hollywood hills that
night hey i tell you what i'm not gonna
tell them
when it comes to you if they start doing
an autopsy on you i'm not going to tell
stay away from his better guy because
that's going into smithsonian they're
going to [ __ ] need two guys to hold
that one hey just
split it down down the middle like hey
you know what closing
did he never clean down here
that's right it's gonna take them two
weeks to get the smell off their hands
hey stop wearing that skin that's not a
hat bring it back
[Laughter]
hey uh uh let me ask you a question
because you know charles manson wasn't
at the at
uh you know alleged not at the murder of
of of that i like to say the names but
of those people
on cielo drive he was not there he
wasn't in the house
yeah
and you can still be charged for
multiple murders if you're not if you
don't take a hand in the murder
yeah because he was the he was the guru
that put it all together
he's a co-conspirator even though he
didn't pull the trigger he's he's a
co-conspirator
because he put it all together had them
doing things on his behalf
so they said what if he said hey they're
lying well i guess they had the trial
right yeah they had the trial and
somebody said
charlie you're lying
right you know when i was a young pretty
sure any and interesting even back then
before
even back then before cameras in the
courtroom like everybody's watching
johnny depp
and that trial that was in virginia
people thought it was in hollywood that
was a crazy trial um i think i might
offer amber heard a gig on my show i'm a
pair
million dollars an episode
15 weeks
don't
pay does it get you even
that's awesome 13 [ __ ] million
dollars
the days of million dollar episodes are
gone
oh yeah a million dollars i remember one
time ray romano was driving into the lot
and and he was driving a navigator and i
had a [ __ ] turbo porsche and i said
god the only the difference between he
and i
are these cars and at 825 000 a week
they don't pay anybody like that anymore
you could be the most talented
[ __ ] in the world like
35 take it or leave it i'll take it you
know
so how are those uh was that another
comic com another crime convention you
went to i'm going to be all over so by
the time i was the day
i'll be the [ __ ] pig flying over the
audience
it was a
100 year
anniversary of sheriff's homicide bureau
and so it was a big event
it was a nice big event was alex there
uh yes he was
yes he was what do you say about me what
do you say about being in the podcast i
i talked to him and he said everything
is coming out positive he liked it i was
with him that night then i went out and
did some stuff with him on uh
uh saturday morning yesterday morning
and he's very very happy i apologize i'm
not gonna be with him
uh tuesday night election night
uh where i'm hoping he gets that 50 plus
one i'm gonna be in chicago but
uh his wife guaranteed me
they're going to facetime me
what what uh what are you going to
chicago for
a great event here it's i'm going back
to talk to uh
wounded injured veterans
and uh
some surviving family members of uh cops
killed in the line of duty
i'm do and it's just for a podcast but i
guess this podcast they got a decent
spot i think cbs may be sponsoring them
uh i'm going down there i take this
first time i've ever taken a red-eye
special
going in tonight
and get there tomorrow morning arrive at
six going straight to a golf course
and where i'm not playing golf george
you know i don't do that but i'll go out
there and be with the guys the veterans
that are injured i've been in combat
uh cheer them up
and then tuesday uh and then or take me
to this private i think it's a private
cops club this is hey the [ __ ] flows
over there and we're going to go in
there for a monday night tuesday i have
a podcast with that's when we do the
podcast then a nice steak dinner
well let me tell you something
if this is your first red eye when you
land you better get into that evidence
locker and get some coke because you're
going to be
[ __ ] falling on your ass
you're going to be flat out your ass by
noon hey
i took a red eye and i take them all the
time and i had a meeting at 10 30 and i
landed at 7 30 and and they ended up
canceled the meeting and there was no
way that i was going to [ __ ] be able
to talk at 10 30 in the morning i was
almost dead
well
fortunately when i get there i don't
have to talk about the house
have
particularly
[Laughter]
but not with their hands just one of
those things was the things they used
a little feather duster
all day good old days
you know sometimes
you get harder with people
they put that one down
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm writing that down i think my husband
needs viagra though i think you just
need some [ __ ] new choice
right out of you
i thought i had it right now this
function but i knew what i just needed
away
everybody spent all this money on
medicine just everybody going
[Laughter]
all the falls [ __ ] pink click be like
everybody used to want fentanyl now that
they just wanted viagra
[Laughter]
yeah it's funny that your body
deteriorates as you uh
as you get older man i mean i i hear
when we're working i bought the director
a scooter and i said i think i'll get
myself one
the difference between having a scooter
and having to instead of having to walk
back and forth like a [ __ ] brand new
man at the end of the day yeah you know
[ __ ]
[ __ ] back and forth all day they're
like oh they're ready for you and you're
like oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] scooter of
course
you know [ __ ] splash you almost cut
the side of my face off for the [ __ ]
i was like truck
[Laughter]
when i was like
you know what i'm happy for you man
because i like i said you know you you
we get to see you every week so
you always have an answer for whatever
questions we ask and there and it's
always a good it's always a proper
answer you're not like me you know
but you know those guys
and that's why i think is that everybody
that's kind of been in crime
first of all doesn't have the
credentials that you have and they've
all been through the through the [ __ ]
mill already it's almost like hey you
want to go see you know you want to go
see this band up like i seen that
[ __ ] battle
[ __ ] it's not even that original
but so you're but you're
that thing is still new it's fresh
and um i think they're doing a didn't
didn't uh uh aaron said that dude aren't
they doing a night stalker like [ __ ]
uh uh uh mini series or something
i don't know what they're doing
they do they do stuff i have people
calling me i'm i'm still waiting for uh
ben uh
hernandez
your buddy the director you know who's
playing you know who's gonna play
richard ramirez mario lopez he's gonna
stop working out for a week
i'm still waiting to see what whatever
follows up with if he's ever going to do
anything oh because we had that show the
foothill show yeah yeah he said he
wanted a new movie
yeah well he'd want to do a movie but i
have a show
i shouldn't say it is about
the last detective
from the rodney king era is about to
retire
from the foothill division in
uh pocoyma
those guys were brutal
all right
almost they were i'm not saying they're
very nice now you got some friends
i ain't saying [ __ ] you're talking about
the blue beanies
those dudes man you know they kick your
ass instead of having to learn how to
run
i didn't chase nobody listen
you know unless you've ever been
either pushed by a night stick or i've
had the pleasure of being hit by one
you don't ever really
you think what is hard the [ __ ] nice
thing has a [ __ ] lead center
and
not only that not that then the
psychological effect of having them
stand over you say you want more
[ __ ] and then whoever thought of
putting the brace on there
just went from like like like like
[ __ ] aquaman to the bottle that could
breathe underwater and fly
and throw webs and [ __ ] little guests
can get any girl like you look over here
he just you know and i i mean whoever
put the brace on it
forget it
it's like tubing you know tubing
everybody can do
water skiing was tough though the one
finn hardly but
if you can if you can
i've seen dudes do the night stick were
they
almost like the meanest [ __ ]
marching band in the world and twirling
i got a drum major
request in front of this band the bucket
hit you in the leg with it hey i'm no
good with the staff but
they could bust your kneecap in one and
one in one chair sure that that that new
one with the handle the they used to
call it pr24 you they teach you how to
use it with the handle move that thing
run
and
i was no good with the sap i already
told you that one went flying out of my
hand but with that stick i have broken
lip i have broken a leg
i you know i i have one that that is
called a p uh uh pr
a pc dm is that a pidgey don't move
those are what you get over there the
flea market
but you know but you know in in um
first of all the pot the podcast
the whole idea of a podcast got very
very successful real fast and then you
know people used to either like walk
their dogs and listen to it and then
[ __ ] get attacked by some [ __ ]
people because they're not listening or
[ __ ] running to get hit by a [ __ ]
car because you know they're listening
to marc maron
yeah uh uh but but but
the crime i think i don't know what the
top podcasts are but i would
i would assume that
crime is up heavy on the on the uh
nobody nobody has a podcast about you
know how to how to live better or watch
that [ __ ] it's just it's just crying
yeah yeah that's my favorite murder is
one of the biggest podcasts crime con
and then that stuff in chicago and let
me tell you man
you think you you know
the little vhf [ __ ]
vcr [ __ ] every tuesday
and those guys
until you [ __ ] until you meet some
chicago cops bro that it's gonna be like
it's gonna that's gonna be like jumping
out of an airplane versus running around
with a little pinwheel out of your car
those dudes in chicago they're
they're they're legit man oh i've met
some former cops from chicago they are
legit matter of fact as soon as my
daughter found out that i was going
she's got friends that come out here
so she right away and she's dad they're
ready to take care of they're ready to
do it i said sweetheart you know i ain't
got that much time i'm going over there
these guys i'm going to be with these
guys don't worry about it but they are
and i and i've helped them out when they
come down here to l.a once i found out
they were cops hey let's roll it out for
them let me let me tell you that this
may have happened
may have not happened may have happened
i was going to the funny firm in the 90s
somebody said hey i got a friend of mine
that can get you some tickets to the
cubs
i said oh yeah he goes yeah he'll be out
there in the corner waiting for you and
i said okay i don't know what i look
like and i'm waiting to rather go
where's this [ __ ] guy there's a cop
there's an oh there's a police officer
in the middle of the street cause you
george
and i go yeah and he goes i'm the guy he
gave him some money we just with the
pocket that had the badge and he took
him out
that's awesome
i wish i had more time i'm gonna get
busted that's for sure
i wish i had more time because the
dodgers are gonna be back there playing
the white sox oh you know so if i
extended it and they offered me say you
want to go to the game
when is that
dude you got to stay now i can get your
tickets
yeah they're playing the white sox uh
all i gotta do is change my flight
they're playing on wednesday hey i'll
put you in the owner i know the owner of
the of the white sox jerry and then uh
uh tony larussa and the dodgers
they [ __ ] [ __ ] that man
every week they got a [ __ ] 13 year
old playing a new position
hey we're still in first place brother
hey i don't know where they [ __ ] pull
these dudes out of man she now
you know what it doesn't have a little
league dusty baker was 71 years old when
he retired
is a member at uh
uh where i play golf
and
um
you know you know we grew up thinking
that that the biggest guy
or the most muscular guy was the fastest
best guy
you know he doesn't have an ounce of fat
on him all muscle but but you know he's
he's he's not the tallest guy and this
dude is
one of the best and freddie friedman
whatever about those names freddie
freddie fender whatever
this team is like this team is like one
of those teams the [ __ ] yankees would
have had in the 50s man they're that
good
hey and this guy this guy turner
slides like he's go like he's on air
brother he's bad the [ __ ] dodgers hey
their right feeler doesn't have a spine
and that [ __ ] is still out there
every day
he was born without a spine yeah
still a good story he just had like a
hangers at the people
what's going on
so i endorsed rick caruso after after uh
uh talking to you know to you guys and
having alex on and then uh actually
caruso called me himself
is that right
i think i think he saw the podcast and
he said you know and i told him i said
hey man you know i asked these guys
asked alex asked you know uh uh uh um
and about about you and and why would
you want the gig and he's like hey
i just want the city to be better than
it is
i i believe it and we talked about the
homeless stuff when we talked about you
know our our current mayor you know
even even if like alex said the five
kings which is which is
you know man it's like you know
a guy that's under that amount of
scrutiny who's still free enough to talk
about the people that i mean it's really
like they're adversaries but you go how
come the mayor doesn't have the power
that the mayor had when we were coming
up is because they have this committee
you know the five kings and um i think
we're seeing now that
um
a lifelong politician
or somebody who
um
maybe
have people in their pocket that that
that kind of anonymity doesn't last
forever and you see some people who who
are being accused
uh on on the you know council and on the
in the border or whatever the city
that you know you can stay too long you
know
you can stay you can stay too long
he's you know and i'm glad uh
i mean you even got snoop dogg
endorsing crusoe
i mean so now that's got to be a
tremendous that goes a long time
and and once he wins and and
yesterday when i was with alex he didn't
mention crucial by name
but he believes
uh there's going to be a definitive
change and he's really hoping to work
closely they'll have a lot better
relationship
and i'm sure he's talking about mr
caruso
and so i'm hoping i told the wife right
away you know i don't live in los
angeles
he's got it you know he's he doesn't
have to do this stuff you know they they
uh they they write articles about him
being um
uh
you know um like i don't know but the
investigator is the right word but being
looked at
everybody should be looked at and if you
look at the other politicians they're
being looked at too it's not just you
know everybody gets looked at and he's
you know whatever whatever people
believe they're going to believe what
they do what they're going to believe
what they hear not what they know like
we're in a place now where they're going
they're going to believe what they hear
and not what's been proven you can
malign somebody and then that person
will be
you know i don't know who's [ __ ] in the
bed but
whoever
johnny dipped my life
i have a fear
the size of it you can tell by the size
of it because you know dudes
[ __ ] monkey [ __ ] monkey kale
[ __ ]
jay paul up for junior's wallet
it's like you know when you used to go
buy shoes the bigger shoes were for the
men and the little ones that they'd have
to open were for the ladies i mean come
on
but now you can have a ladies woman
against another lady that's a [ __ ]
size 14 shoe
[Laughter]
with a little fin with a little fin on
her surfboard underneath
hi i'm george lopez and i'm single girls
married manscape has helped you keep
keep yourself in the game if you were a
long distance runner and there was a
runner that was way better than everyone
else and you could stay close to him
that was a victory i think of the same
thing with pubes if you let your [ __ ]
grow wild and nobody can see the address
of your house and you're like what the
hell is going on down there
landscape
is their
new platinum package 4.0 it's the
biggest bundle that they're offering and
they're giving you a discount on all of
the manscape top products listen
i'm not a member of of manscape's uh uh
financial but i would just say when i
look down there and i can see
what i want to see you know sometimes
the clouds get in the way almost like
pedals i'm happier and you'll be happier
too so inside of the platinum plus
package you'll find a lot more 4.0 a
trimmer a weed whacker that's what i
need weed whacker and then a nose hair
trimmer there's nothing for the oil for
body wash ultra premium 201 shampoo
conditioner ultra premium deodorant crop
preserver anti-chafing ball deodorant
i've been in this hotel room a long time
i'm getting tired of my own
and a travel bag to hold all the goodies
while you're traveling oh
i'm serious you're not taking the
[ __ ] i can almost tell what time it
body trimmer and weed whacker nose and
ear trimmer feature proprietary advanced
skin safe technology to protect your
delicate parts and holes both are
waterproof so you can shave with less
mess
in addition to shaving you can now
completely upgrade your shower routine
with the ultra premium body wash and
ultra premium two in one shampoo plus
conditioner
you'll have your skin and hair feeling
hydrated and smelling fresh don't forget
to apply your aluminum free ultra
premium deodorant for the color quality
scent on the go but it's not just your
pits that stank
your balls tank too
thankfully their crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver ball toner can
solve this problem for you
once they touch your sack you'll never
go back let me tell you something
manscape is so good i will miss smelling
my own [ __ ] levels there in the
middle
whatever time in the morning
are you just a [ __ ] little
venetian like a little fan
you go down you're like oh
and you know what you're smell like
we're gonna take the
hey they're gonna take the pleasure out
of my days off
get 20 percent up and free shipping with
the code
omg hi at manscape.com listen if you
listen to this to this podcast and it
sounds like you know we're not serious
this is a part of of i think grooming
because all of viejas have the little
charlie chaplin but i don't think hey
but
they prepare for you you better prepare
for them that's what i'm saying so 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code omghi because you
circumcised and uncircumcised there's
not a lot we can do about that maybe
pull the sun sunroof back put the
sunroof back up but i'll unlock
your big groom energy with manscape
because if you're circumcised and
rebecca says like oh i love them like
guys on a server side and you peel it
back like the [ __ ] tortuga at the la
the big one i think and remember when
you trim the hedges the trees stand tall
mateo was founded by a group of friends
passionate about having cbd
and bringing it to those who love it the
most so if you haven't heard of cbd it
could promote relaxation sleep and a
slew of other benefits
so topicals like like a hemp infused uh
manuka cream or on the go pain relief
roll on
help you balance your skin your body and
your mind deep sleep gummies support the
journey to finding deep relaxing sleep
that leads to
a rejuvenating day i'll tell you
something you know like so many people
were against cbd and thc and it goes
back to even guild when we first started
doing the show guild you said like hey
man i'm of the mind that if somebody had
a joint it was a felony to have a joint
right
yeah
so of all of these things
i mean i'm not sure when it happened
because it may be happened in denver
first
and then
even even if it's not thc that's legal
where you live like where i am right now
cbd is legal but i would much rather
take cbd
than take something over the counter
from your pharmacy
prescribed by your doctor or not
prescribed by your doctor that's all i'm
saying our industrial hemp has grown in
america and is u.s hip authority
certified
our products are third party tested no
gmo contains organic ingredients and
grain free right so omg hi listeners get
thirty percent off and free shipping
with their order from badera so
so go to madera.com
omghi and enter the code
omghi
at checkout so 30 off
that's a lot you go down there
and try it if you don't like it don't
try it again but i'm going to tell you
right now from me
and
i've been you know having trouble
sleeping my whole life that i've been on
the road there's nothing that works like
madeira and these products and it'll
work for you and you don't even have the
schedule that i have
i'll try to get up at seven to fly away
what do we have to deal with uh are we
doing calls or what are we doing
uh we're just
shouting it out today you got another
one
i did andrew was a big boy and i was i
had the guitar on my hand and he said
play us out and i was like i could be
like
my hand fell asleep
the big one was like just like oh [ __ ]
he can't play he's like all right and
this hand was the
man i've been gone a long time i've been
i've been out here since uh
the middle of april back and forth a
little bit but
yeah but then you've got a couple weeks
left too don't you
oh i got more than a couple weeks
i'm moving to another to another part of
the country for six weeks
i won't be back till
the statute of limitation wears out
allegedly i'll be back just in time to
start the other show
oh do you have any idea when that starts
uh i think early august
but this has been fun man i mean you
know there's there's not we can't post
any pictures and can't really
kind of talk about it but um
you know there's a there's a model
that's from brazil bruno um
she's got like 43 million i can't
pronounce her last name because it's
latino sound and i've been i've been
around the [ __ ] wrong people for too
long i always used to be like
that
i was like uh
but you know we did a thing yesterday
and we were together all day in this in
the car and we were you know drive
racing i was driving and
man
she was great
funny and in it and also and we started
slow because you know the the um you
know we're not we're gonna we're in a
sound stage and it's like green screen
and they have to imagine that 10 things
are happening at the same time it's hard
to get
the 10 thing in a sequence and then make
it look natural
and by the end by
you know by the
you know
for second part of the day
at the end man we just it was [ __ ]
great man great
had you had much uh experience with
working with like the green screen stuff
before it's all like you're kind of
learning that you got it you know
usually the green screen's been behind
me and i'm [ __ ] in front of them
in front you have to see a [ __ ]
fireball and
a [ __ ] uh guy that's half metal
running at you
yeah what's that been like do you feel
like you're getting used to it at this
point or does it still feel sort of like
weird
um
yesterday was a big day in that
was a big day because the the earlier
before we had done stuff but
not to the degree of
an actual action day
of driving a car and
you know
i mean i did
move things that i've done where i've
driven a car you've actually driven the
car you know they go hold the traffic
listening man the car never moved all
day the cameras moved and the cars did
oh man
that's a trip
and then they have uh
nike i think that's too much and then
they have special cameras that
are for
a special effect angle or angles that
aren't that aren't that's not a regular
camera i mean it's [ __ ] i mean man
you know what man they got that this arm
that comes down
right so the camera's already like you
see this coming at you and then it can
turn around 360
and just
do all of this at the sa at the same
time man it's like dude that's funky is
it hard to not like look at that as
you're like have to like stay in the
scene but you see this crazy like tech
thing
i would do this they go say this over
here and then look over here and i would
be like hey get out of there and i would
be like they go cut i said wow what
happened i forgot to look back
yeah that's that's gotta be tough are
you a million dollar camera what did
they have you look at a piece of [ __ ]
tape
like a tennis ball with a million
dollars ago i take a little piece of
tape look at this
oh yeah man
that's good
it's funny man i've been doing it for
you know 43 years i've been doing
stand-up and i think in my career
of all the things that i've had i think
right now maybe potentially next year
being the one of the best years i've had
yeah that's great i've had good years
but yeah
[ __ ] if you're saying that's going to be
the best year you've had
you know what have you seen a lot of
these great and i ain't [ __ ] with
anybody you know i'm i'm taking it very
careful
like i'm not i'm not making i'm not
picking fights i'm not doing [ __ ] i was
like hey
yeah yeah you're not thinking so i can
say anything i want to and you're not
gonna say anything bad about them no
[Laughter]
yeah but but it's uh it's you should
stay man let me know if you want to stay
over there
oh okay you mean chicago
hey when you go with those guys what
won't you drink like that like like like
if i go with people like tonight we're
having a little party before that i'm
gonna go see david gilmour but then i
got to get up early in the morning but
but i wouldn't do
shots at the pre-party
or maybe i would but
i you know i don't know if i would
because i want to go see david gilmour
not not yeah you got to pace yourself a
little bit and the only reason i i mean
i'm going to go for the music but i love
that it breaks it up and when that
concert's over i'm going to come back
and go to sleep if i stayed at that
party
yeah well
here's the problem you know like
yesterday i had a thing in the morning
with the sheriff and then the afternoon
i had a college grad you know a
graduation thing i had to go do at the
graduation i wouldn't drink at all and i
told the wife i said i'm not gonna drink
i don't want to drink
i got it's been a long day tomorrow i
have the podcast and then i'm flying out
tomorrow night so i didn't want to drive
so i didn't touch alcohol all day
nothing
when i go over there i hate drinking the
night before i'm gonna leave
because i know i got to get up and fly
back we're supposed to go out to a nice
steak dinner
if i stay an extra day
i've already committed to uh i don't
know if you've ever heard of this guy
his name is mobile
so i'm doing
i'm doing a podcast with momo thursday
night
yeah you'll get back in time yeah if i
could if i can get but you're going to
see the giant to go see the dodgers on
the white side that's like old
yeah yeah yeah
i'll probably end up
explaining to the wife
you know i didn't want to do but george
made me
george
you got me on the field everything
got the evidence right here just show
her the podcast
he's a good dude
good
good i'd love to
i'd love to you know what is a great guy
yeah
one time i called him up one time we
were talking about we were in las vegas
and uh i called him up and it was
probably like 3 30 i forgot he was back
east and he answered
and he had had a game
because we were watching the highlights
i called him up and he's like hello say
hey tony's joy hey what's up man what's
going on
i forgot that he was
you know had a game that night was like
a sunday night game
did you give him that old drunk day hey
what are you doing what are you doing i
always call people on their phone
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you know i i need two one for
the the guy that's taking me to the game
my sh the guy's going all around with me
who's that
oh yeah uh the guy's name is rick uh
[ __ ] let me see here
caruso
rick caballero
oh pretty cool oh
what is he what is he
he's a retired cop he's also a veteran
oh he got in the corner
uh
where what's going on he just sent me a
text while i was with you guys just
telling me
what would you like to drink while
you're here
oh all righty mines
oh
great
some breast milk okay i bet you'd bring
some [ __ ]
what's science
uh
[Laughter]
it's one of my favorite uh it's one of
my favorite cities
well i i'm looking forward to it you
know out of all the speaking stuff that
i've done to be able to go talk
for wounded bits
uh it's very important yeah it really is
so i've got it all and fully it's very
chicano town because you can walk and
you can get a hot dog at the same time
we let him go
there you go
that's me
yeah
no no i mean yeah you've done both man
you've done uh
you've done both you did you did your
your service man
you know i heard so much at the
anniversary 100 year anniversary of the
night i had so many guys come up to me
and say congratulations they want to
take pictures
but they said we also saw the thing that
you did with your old captain from
vietnam
and
that was very very touchy
still very very heartfelt to me
so to be with these guys
if i can give him a ray of hope
put a smile on her face
[ __ ] i might feel like george lopez for
a second
somebody's face no yeah yeah i well
thank you man i i saw a guy uh a guy
named carter davis uh
in the airport and uh
he uh
he had an organization that helped
veterans get gym memberships uh because
you know i think or or catch catch like
22 like i think maybe at that time 22
guys a day would commit suicide
and uh he said you know i had this
organization or have it
and
he would uh try to get
gyms to give memberships to veterans so
they had something to some place to go
and not stay in the house
and i and i started to work with that
guy and give him money and stay
comfortable
god bless you thank you i've done a lot
of stuff man i've done a lot of veteran
stuff
you gave me a hat
you told me you couldn't get rid of the
[ __ ] once i get my hat
you know what i get my driver from uh
from here from
here a hat yesterday and he goes oh
thank god i said [ __ ] when i get
somebody a hat
i expect some [ __ ] eight top service
counter
so he brought me a bag i got a bag right
here of beer and and and all kinds of
things he brought that up there
yeah that's good for you man i like that
what's momo doing the paranormal still
did you go to them uh yeah yeah i went
to his birthday party the other night it
was nice warm family you know a few
comedians here the i had met the guy
before
uh the guy who helps write for uh
deal deal hugely
and uh i met him
dude
yeah yeah yeah that's what he looks like
i didn't call him the indian dude but
yeah that's what he looked like
and
what kind of vehicle does that do that
could be in two places at one time
i i i don't know he was there
and just a nice guy just like d.l
and we had uh great conversation with
nice uh
aj the paranormal guy the reader he was
there
uh familia from momo he was nice i stood
there for a while then i took off but i
promised he showed me his nice new in
his house he's got a nice studio
to record his podcast with
uh so i'm going to be with him uh
thursday night
for a podcast and then he's got an
upcoming uh comedy show that i told my
i'd go be out there
and the other i told them as long as i
get to park where i did last time they i
get to score around where no cars go and
yeah
the owner lets me park there oh and that
in that club over there by where he
lives
yeah yeah the
but
i'm almost like yeah i sold it out i'm
[ __ ] 47 people
[Laughter]
excelling at a [ __ ] doctor's waiting
room
[ __ ] tickets downtown
hey sorry mobile i'm not laughing at you
brother i'm laughing with george we're
laughing
but when we laugh our chichis don't
bounce like
yours uh and george you just had a
stand-up anniversary didn't you i think
i saw something um 43 years old [ __ ]
god bless you congratulations
i'd be retired i'm pretty sure thank you
yeah congrats that's awesome that's
that's a whole last career you're still
going sure you know
knowing myself as i know as i know
myself now you know in these times that
you think about
you know
i just
you know i
i mean when you go to college man you
you go there and you're reading a book
and then somebody's trying to teach you
but when you do stand up or you go if
you're in a band or anything in that
area or whatever
you go to a club and you're not gonna do
well and you know you're not gonna do
well and then you're gonna be like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] and you're gonna go back and
do it again and again and again and
again for years and then when i was
telling somebody about
how long i've been doing it i said well
you know 79 i was still in high school
and then 89 i did arsenio
my career i can tell you the four
there's like four points in the 40 years
79
89 i did arsenio
91 i did the tonight show 2001 i signed
to do my show 2002 the show aired
2007 it ended 2009 the talk show 12 talk
show was over 14 lopez tonight
and
this one but in between
six
five eight wheel specials and a couple
other specials and all the animated
movies and books and all that [ __ ] in
between
so you know somebody says oh you know
for a latino comedian he's probably the
most successful
uh i would put the tale of the tape of
my [ __ ] 20 43 years against
a lot of comedians
well i i responded to your instagram
congratulations and thank you
for everything you've done
for fans around the world
and locals here and i thank you for
everything and you know uh and you guys
know that as uh as entertaining as i am
on camera i'm i'm much
[ __ ] more entertaining away from it
and i think that's what the podcast
people when people watch the podcast or
watch it they go you know what i like
that is i i like the you can hear the
wheels turn you can see the wheel
and this [ __ ] comes out with which you
can't do that and you can would stand
wrong and you see what happens go up
there they [ __ ] slap you or some
[ __ ] mini dude that wants to be a
lady has a [ __ ] gun with a knife in
it you know
and it's like you know you got to be
careful and you know if there was a job
that you could get [ __ ] slap standing
in front of the hollywood ball for 18
000 people with 11 spotlights in your
eyes
but it's been it's been you know
yeah it's been it's been it's been it's
been uh it's been all right
i was wondering because of stuff like
the books and animated shows or the
movies and talking was there anything
that like surprised you the most what
you ended up doing like you never would
have expected at the start of your
career you know
i never thought i would have my own show
you know i remember
remember tim allen
showtime special and he was on stage in
indianapolis and he said
during in his act he said i just signed
to do my my own show
uh with abc and then home improvement
was like huge man huge like number one
number one i was never i wasn't a top 10
a couple weeks when i was behind in the
right time spot but
that show and his career and everything
and i remember watching him
and when you watched him
all the whole tools and the
that grunting more power thing
all the whole home improvement show
was in his stand-up and i remember
thinking back there and just looking at
myself and going i don't have any
[ __ ] thing in my act that
it resembles anything that would be
considered a show so
from from
88
to
2002
um
a lot of ups and downs in there but
on the up
you know in the in in from from 95 to 99
were dark times for me but but um
when i stopped worrying about what
everybody else was doing in 99
um
i think man the universe reset itself
for me i never i didn't imagine and then
you know you you get you get a call they
go oh i got a meeting with this guy but
the the but
the
points between
getting a phone call
having a meeting having another meeting
i don't know let me have somebody else
the [ __ ] points that have to fall in
line at the same
at the right time in order for you to
even debut one week much less than 20
weeks it's just it's the [ __ ] odds
against uh
are almost virtually impossible i
remember when cheech told me one time he
looked at me and he put his hand on my
face and he says man
i'm proud of you man i said well that
why he's
he says you know i was thinking about
the matter dude like you hit it out of
the park your first time at bat nobody
does that
and i was like wow that's
it's from
your grandma as a child then you end up
with an overweight mexican retired cop
like me
it's like a
it's like a [ __ ] ghost that misses
mural
[Laughter]
young dude with some old [ __ ] ghost
in some [ __ ] house that she bought
dude that's right
oh yeah you couldn't do those shows
anymore
everything is paranormal
and everything is crime and
yeah man
you know here here you know with the
phone you can if you have netflix
you know the tv doesn't have you know
doesn't have cable uh per se but if you
have you know this app you can watch
hulu and you can watch you know netflix
and showtime and stuff but all the [ __ ]
that's that trends man is all
stuff that
at another time they wouldn't let you
watch it like if you know we were we
were kids they wouldn't your mom would
go they go hey turn that [ __ ] i don't
want you watching that [ __ ] yeah yeah
all that stuff that we end up watching
if my daughter doesn't have to hurt
my grandson they've never seen a netflix
documentary and they're 10 and six
do you think do you think that you think
that those video games because i mean
i'm not a video gamer i'm not a gamer so
i don't know the games that are out
there but the games that are out there
that involve war
are [ __ ] violent man and they're more
reality based it's almost like what you
would see
when a when uh when when when they
either uh
somebody at war or somebody that was a
police officer would see almost like
real time the the the
optics are so [ __ ] good that do you
think that that [ __ ]
desensitizes
people to or not people desensitizes
who all the people that are committing
that [ __ ] kid in texas man that
[ __ ] 18 year old kid
i i don't think so george i i think
those kids you know i forget the
comedian that said it
uh i can see him i i want to say it was
chris rock that said
you know because when they first had the
big colorado shooting where all the kids
were
he says they used to call they blame it
on the television they blame it on
parent they blame it on it whatever
happened to they're just [ __ ] crazy
you know and and and so when we were
kids
we had roy rogers we had gene autry they
were shooting the [ __ ] out of each other
we had combat
you know they were that would they they
were shooting the [ __ ] up
but
we didn't go bad you know we didn't
follow that today's games they're into
it they play them i don't think that
really influences them
but i'm not a doctor in my opinion i
don't think that makes him a killer
what about gunsmoke and the rifleman
they're [ __ ] in the fire in the
[ __ ] title
every wanted to be like and he was a
baseball player too
so connor yeah you know everybody want
to be like the rifleman what other ones
do they have uh
the lone ranger
you know
[Applause]
my grandmother one time told me hey
who took the kleenex out of my car if
you say that you know all the old ladies
have clinics oh yeah yeah i took it out
because
i already gone through
the biggest marathon
i'm gonna use your [ __ ] seat covers
next
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] birds are [ __ ] inside my
car how are they doing
hey brother
oh this was gonna really piss off the
family i got to my swingless house one
night and she is pissed off and i said
my father-in-law let me say what what's
wrong what's wrong what can you do about
it what could you do i was already a cop
i said do my what
she says we were driving down the
freeway right now and i saw some girl
giving that guy he was leaning over in
his crotch and they were
and i said
what she was not with her i said
oh she was orally copulating him instead
of just saying oh she was giving him a
[ __ ] and she said yes
what can we do about it i said watch it
and enjoy it
yeah say thanks for the show
man that's got choice
that's what they said what can we do
about it
um
years ago in indianapolis
a young comedian was being fellated
uh and and on the way down
jumped out i don't think i was ready for
that jumped the curb and flattened a
[ __ ] tire
in his uh [ __ ] chevy tahoe i'm bent
axle
dangerous
the only time this young comedian ever
ever uh uh uh
ever left the car and reported it stolen
but but he left residue inside but he
was never traced back that that was
before they used dna
[Laughter]
i just told him that some bird [ __ ]
inside my car
oh my god i wouldn't recommend that was
the most danger i got into as a young
adult
uh
yeah there's risk involved that's for
sure
so let's go what else is going on george
um
what's going on let's see we're coming
into the summer though i think right
yeah yeah
um i don't know man dude here in the
here where i am
um
possibly the worst the worst drivers
that uh
and a lot of crime now rapper just got
killed last night in his car or like
sitting in his car
yeah man
you know i think i think you know
i think one of the things that we talked
about this before like not doing things
at night that you don't need to do that
you do during the
day i think that's a good way to come
back like if you're like oh i forgot
that it is i forgot [ __ ] spaghetti
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] man like
don't go don't go out there
it's it's
really dangerous
yeah simple simple things just help
people don't leave anything in your car
try not to have packages delivered that
might sit outside if somebody's not
there to receive them don't [ __ ] park
your bike on the thing
and and and don't go out at night or go
get gas at night
if you're by yourself
and don't get caught giving them a bonus
somebody shouldn't be hey
tahoe don't [ __ ] blow your load
coming off
[Laughter]
[Music]
what happened here i said spider-man
hit me i moved right there on the
dashboard
i'm gonna say um
what's gonna say
about that
man about but i think that
oh man it's right here it's but but i
think that i think that and the crime of
[ __ ] man i mean remember we're coming
off that [ __ ] pandemic where nobody
did [ __ ] for two years that includes
[ __ ] criminals like if they're
[ __ ]
yeah every two years without jacking
people man like
and and if you're taking
you know
i think it's a medicine that you know
taking a lot of medicine from i think
but also you know
i like to uh i like i don't like i don't
know why they call it recreational drugs
because you take when you're like that
you don't look like you're gonna be
doing anything recreational for a long
time
[Music]
i would say i would say that if there's
people out there that are casual drug
users
to
to avoid
as much as you can because that [ __ ]
fenelon is it's in all of these things
man
yeah it's an all it's in all this [ __ ]
like you think hey your friend gave you
a pill you know your back hurts
i would say i would say for people to be
careful because that [ __ ] man is
their their their prince i mean prince
was was uh addicted to
you know painkillers but then he got
pills that had that fennel in him he was
done man i mean like you can do it one
time
i was watching something in in the
documentary that this this the daughter
had uh uh um
a prescription and got up they got a
pill for each other back hurt
gave it to her and she od man on that
man
it's like you can't see it so it could
be in something legitimate you think
you're thinking
don't put fennel in the viagra brother
richard pryor said you'll come and go at
the same time that's right
you thought he was coming and he was
going they'll find you and you'll be
like that you know like those cats they
sell in mexico they're like that they
just [ __ ] ground by the arm and take
them away
yeah it's it's it's uh we're living in
in in uh dangerous times man
and if you're on tinder why are we
talking about going on tinder and if
you're going on tinder dates with with
somebody you don't know man that you're
listen
neither what's the number again
uh
leave the 818-533-1843 and your
measurements and i'll buy you
[Laughter]
one of the few gifts i have is measuring
the right dildo to the right person
there you go
there you go i'm opening the company too
just we're just starting to get the
license dildos by george
hey can we call it
we can call it what
anonymously
yes we'll call it the
palitos
[Laughter]
no but i mean i mean uh um
yeah
the dating sites and all that [ __ ]
matters is [ __ ] there was a doctor the
guy that wanted to be a doctor on
craigslist there was killing broads they
got him up in new york i believe listen
because everybody wants to be in shape
now they can put you in a [ __ ]
suitcase and you fit before they would
have to be like what am i going to do
with this body they don't know if
they've done that
hey that's why
hey
what about the doctor that was a
fertility doctor i would and when his
procedures didn't work he put his own
mecca in there
see that's why i don't worry about being
kidnapped or slaughtered put a suitcase
there's too much of me brother
i'll be like who's that over there oh
yeah u-haul's coming tomorrow to pick
that up
the guy i needed another guy was we just
closed it come and pick it up but but
you like that um
it's on hbo and then it's on netflix
where
the the
the babies didn't have any traits of the
[ __ ]
it was the [ __ ] die they went they
they went to the doctor
you know sometimes old people can look
like babies look at that [ __ ] doctor
look like 17 kids look like the doctor
yeah
i remember that is this um is it baby
god is that what it's called baby god
and another one another one and the
doctor would use you know it's almost
like if you know if if somebody's around
they go give me that specific where did
she go and then you know what
with a 99
rate
only one lady spit it out
[Laughter]
oh that's
good i think my it's like
oh no no not something else what is that
so will you fill us in on on uh
how how's the podcast doing overall
uh so it's doing solid i'd say the
average um
you know spoilers for listeners yeah
listeners change around like twenty five
thousand to thirty thousand per episode
with all like big gas it will strike it
up but uh around that per and uh and
constantly building it's uh you know
it's logged around with these things but
every every week it seems like more than
supply store are you are you
disappointed in where we are
no i think that's just really solid uh
and some of these things as a lot
listeners know it's like these things
are very guest driven right there's not
much of this is around like the
algorithm and stuff like that so when
you have we have like names on people
who are usually on shows that always
helps it blow up too but what's also
cool is people really like the spell
episodes like
it was great to see tony hawk in there
man
that was fun that dude's cool
he was so cool he's the [ __ ] best man
and just the most down to earth just
like normal yes
non-pretentious just he just seemed like
a regular guy and
out of all the guests that have been on
the show since i've been around
uh i was more touched by him than
anybody else they you use really good
it's funny man because um
you know
i think maybe kids that fit in
do team sports and kids that don't fit
in become great at something you could
do alone
right
yeah if you fit in and you have friends
and you're a good athlete and you're
like okay uh
you know i'm on a team and then
eventually like you know
it's funny man because when miami was
playing baseball you know like she
didn't you know all of a sudden it
becomes competitive and it's not fun for
the kids you know
but these [ __ ] emotions hit you and
you know gill like
the first year she played like a farm
team and one of the actors mark moses i
think he was on big actors on desperate
house so he was like the coach and i
would go to the games and stuff and
it was fun for the kids and like they
they you know didn't know where they
were running to and all this and it was
fun and then they had the banquet and
already i feel it like like like all the
kids signed a baseball
so she's in the back and i think she's
even the car seat man and she's holding
the baseball looking at i look back and
she goes daddy look and then i had it
and i was like
all of a sudden you're like
don't
how do you say like
don't ever forget your first team or
like that team
like what it meant to be part of a team
and i was in the car i was like
maybe right now
it's just there's just something about
being a part
of a team with your friends that's
different than
throwing the ball against a wall or
hitting a [ __ ] tennis racquet or or
whatever you want to be a golfer you're
hitting [ __ ] lemons in your backyard
whatever the [ __ ] like i did but when
you're part of a when you when you don't
fit in and you're part of a team
that does good or bad you're still part
of like
his [ __ ] because if you're part of a
team
maybe you won't like one or two guys but
not
the all 13 guys and it's just something
something about that even doing the
movie right here like you know yesterday
was a big day like
everybody gets along and they're all
going to be here this week and and
you're just like man you know
it reminds you of what it's like to be
part of a team and this is we're doing
the work and then next year when it
comes out and if if it is what we
believe it could be it's a [ __ ]
game-changer man it's like you're part
of something that's like like
like for chicanos it's like apple man
this thing's never been done before
you know i i've got to tell you my when
you talk about that my six-year-old my
six-year-old grandson
he really loves baseball loves the
dodgers he wants to get in
he was hurt the other day because i went
to a doctor kane and he wasn't invited
but i mean he's a good little kid he
could smack the [ __ ] out of the ball
he's the biggest guy in the team
and it's just t-ball but he loved it and
he'd hit it and he'd come in he'd slide
in the home plate whether it was a play
or not
and the last game they were in the
playoffs
they lost the game
and they lost the game by one run
so i'm talking to my daughter we were at
the game but i talked to my daughter
later that night i said how's brody
doing well he's okay
and she says but i asked him hey bud did
you did you like playing baseball shoes
yes
and are you happy you did he says no
and
he says why
he says because we lost our last game
he was sad
he was so into it he was sad because
they lost their last game so he's
looking forward to going back and
winning again
you know so he's into what that's a good
point because
what happens now is if everybody gets a
[ __ ] trophy there's no incentive to
be better
and losing makes you
should
losing should be an effective
i'm a loser forget i'm a loser
you want to make yourself better and
come back and win and not keeping score
or everybody you know getting a
participation trophy
i never want to i never wanted champion
i'll be talking about it because i
thought my first year i was correct
the coach didn't like me i was like a
tough to deal with and i think for that
was my penance that i never wanted i
mean when we were literally the
championship was in my hands and i i
didn't deliver but
um
when you stop making things that are
sport about
not winning and losing but
but playing and
the work you put into being a team
you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna win or lose
that that that once you lose the dynamic
of it doesn't [ __ ] matter if i catch
this ball or not we're all going to
[ __ ] end up with the same thing you
you're going to lose
a drive
or or sparking a kid's
drive that's going to drive him for the
rest of his life
that's for sure sure he's different than
his older brother this one's really good
so he he he loves it
and he's waiting for his uh they're
gonna have a party here in a couple of
weeks but he's looking forward to next
year
i'm looking forward my my wife is
you didn't see this on the side
my wife is getting ready to leave the
house
and off to the side she's giving me
instructions
silently
lights out turn the fan off do this do
that because she's getting ready to
leave
so are you going to see her before you
take off to the airport
yes i'll see she's going to drive me
down to the airport tonight
you know if you were younger when you
got back she'd smile your chest to make
sure you weren't
[Laughter]
candy on your chest
i don't know what she's telling me
get her get her on camera say have her
say hi to the audience
come here
come here i don't know
okay you won't be able to hear because
i've got the earpods on but just
just look and see there you are
say hello
hey say hello
tell them all you've given me
instructions i was telling you
that devon
you're very lucky to have uh
somebody like that
i am very lucky
51 years of lucky
what do i have check this out
i got this medal from a cat house in
nevada
this is a three bucket award
[Laughter]
but you know what i as much as sometimes
i wish uh i was with somebody
uh
looking around this room
there's a lot of things that if i was
had a companion and they would be like
you know how to do that you're not doing
that and you're not going to smoke those
two joints in the bedroom
i think it's kind of nice to have a
little bit of freedom for me for me
personally not anybody else i'm talking
about me for me personally people often
ask me when i go out and speak like at
crime con and being at best like that
where's your wife that's exactly why i
don't take her with me that's exactly
and she understands
there are other people out there that
you know you've got a job to do you know
you got to glantan and do what you got
to do i don't have time to be
what do you want for dinner where are we
going so she understands and she gives
me the freedom to do that well i'm just
waiting for one more sponsor but tell
momo he's not invited to what i'm going
to do out there by where he lives called
khan
yeah don't bring your wife
what's the number
eight one eight five three three
eighteen forty three all right i'm gonna
have a kulokan
and you call and leave a message and say
why
maybe you're you're not good with women
why you think you should be invited to
the first annual kurokon
that i'm going to have
over labor day weekend
can i can i add to that
you said why you think you should be
you're not good with women why don't we
add some women to your
guru
i mean women there yeah yeah just see if
they'd like to be part of that
yeah
because
hey kudos number one
yeah and and we'll have uh you know a
month day
that'll be like a pool party
[Laughter]
but you know what i'm gonna do it i'm
going to do
oh my god hi podcast
uh is pearl gone and she's out of the
room yeah she's going we're going to get
a whole show
we're going to go to the i'm just making
the thinking out loud
the viceroy and palm springs
we're gonna get some we're gonna rent it
out and we're gonna have kulokan
it's just like heat out there and just
like sweat and just like a pool to have
the deep end if you're a little bit
heavier you you show up one day and they
have a little flakito day they'll have
thick day a gordita day
we'll show you how to clean yourself
properly we'll have the educational
program how to clean yourself
yeah that's just like a week-long
con it's like a week-long event
movies
where you make noise
we'll have a contest who makes the best
you know noises
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't ask me to be a judge because i'll
just be laughing in the background no i
know
but post send pictures to graham we'll
put them up on the on the oh my god uh
who has that or send them to me i'll do
it
yeah or like dmv instagram or something
like that right the omg hi podcast
instagram yeah yeah let's uh let's start
to post some pictures about uh about
where you are and what you're doing
about who what kind of works i did the
one with you and frank on my on my main
yeah yeah i i saw that
and uh thank you and it was good i'll be
take some pictures up when i'm with the
vets in chicago
and i look forward and hopefully i'll
spend an extra day there
uh you just have to let me know if we're
good we're gonna release two tickets to
go see him on wednesday and i'll come
back i'll come back late yeah
we'll be good
what's today sunday i'll find out where
the white sox are and i'll call them and
uh
white sox the dodgers are going to be
there i know
and so it'll all be good you know i'm
trying to get you in the owner's box but
to go on all right go on the field
all right
that that that sounds great george i'd
certainly appreciate it this mexican
don't get this [ __ ]
like that but
where they are uh look let's see where
they are they're playing right now
they're playing tonight they're here i
think it's playing today here
i think every i think every [ __ ]
major league team plays on sunday don't
they
yeah i think so they literally it
literally starts at 1 10. so the game is
starting at this like very moment
yeah
okay
oh okay i i got i'll i'll call uh yeah i
got it
you know man i used to be the guy i used
to be the kid that was left out and all
of a sudden you're the one that could be
like hey let's do this
it's crazy
that is yeah that's a super power i'm
lucky crazy
yeah
and meanwhile across you get out there
you get to the other uh
apartments that you you know
you don't want to see people that don't
look good naked
hey amen i turn away i see myself i
don't need to look at them
let's go and you know what i i told
grant
uh i want to get uh an upcoming guest i
know you love him george the guy was uh
cut man in
manny pacquiao's corner
uh
met his idol when he was a kid
yeah durant
he met mr duran took him out they had an
in and out burger dated by themselves
the guy's still a working homicide cop
for sheriff's homicide and this is a guy
that tells a story uh he told a story on
another i i said hey is this [ __ ] true
he was a uh working cop went to a
mexican party in east la and you know
how mexican parties are they're all
dancing around making a lot of news this
guy's
they're the theo's laid out in the
driveway they said that's okay we'll
take care of it he's just drunk and
passed out we'll get him inside in a
while he left
he says at four o'clock in the morning
he got a call from somebody named gil
carrillo said hey when you're going to
come back and write a report on this
dead guy
and the guy was dead all the time they
were dancing all around nobody knew it
oh my god no [ __ ]
yeah dude that's so he's ready he's
ready to come on
yeah and he's still an active he's still
an active cut man
on all the pro fights you see
uh
uh
rodriguez mike rodriguez
i am yeah
we'll set it up i met roberto duran in
vegas
in the mid 2000s and he was one of my
favorite fighters of all time
and
when
i took a picture with he they somebody
said to me roberta wants to take a
picture with you i was like what
and then
when i went over to him and
understanding just my hand
and i thought
i was like this you couldn't believe it
you can't believe you can't robert duran
you can watch your head since
well he kissed the wrong head as a god
kiss the left man don't kiss the right
one
yeah the guy's got some great stories
he's still there right now i saw him the
other night again
for the first time in a long time he
puts on bahamas he helps put on homicide
school for guys that come from around
the u.s attended uh he's a good guy
he'd be a great guest i know you'd be
enthused about
good
awesome well when's your concert at
george
my concert is uh
at a hall here in uh
a guy said do you want to be real close
to the stage or further back i said
[ __ ] clothes saying
yeah what kind of question is that i'm
okay if i can get uh because i always
try to get pics from the guys
pete townsend gave me some kicks over
there at the hollywood bowl
oh dude
guy came up to me goes hey uh pete
wanted me to give you these like
uh one a couple said the who with the
with the
arrow and then a couple of them said
pete oh my god
that's awesome so you know when you get
older you know like you know uh uh
the who played the hollywood bowl and
there was a guy in the front row that
kept yelling at at
pete thompson rock and roll and [ __ ]
thousand goes
hey mate
well i should sit down are you [ __ ] i
know it's rock and roll [ __ ]
he tells how he goes this [ __ ] guy
the other rock and roll at me the whole
[ __ ] night and i stick your [ __ ]
ass down
i'm playing i know what the [ __ ] up is
like so funny man
you don't when you're young it's all
noise all the time and when you're older
it's like one you can hear one dude
yelling rock and roll like you can relax
i know it's rock and roll [ __ ] i wrote
this [ __ ]
you practically invented this [ __ ]
but i'm gonna try to get some david
gilmore picks
yeah have you seen him before
i'll see him after and you know i didn't
know that one of the guys that uh danny
zatteslow was this uh
legendary promoter i thought i put coke
in my luggage without me knowing
allegedly um
it's gonna be he flew in from phoenix
i said hey what happened to that shitty
girl i put in your luggage
put a softball of cocaine in my luggage
on my way back to burbank oh
allegedly
the dog didn't sniff it
i think that i put it on my car
the first time i went to europe and you
know
i was all freaked out about bringing
cuban cigars but i've been there for
like three weeks
walking around so i wrapped their cigars
in my car soon as i said that dog can
smell [ __ ] tobacco to all the [ __ ]
calzones
he can have those [ __ ] cigars
when i smoke them i smell like he's like
who [ __ ] farted
and soaked into the leaves
no
all right i gotta go no i don't but it's
been enough enough enough enough
for the day
yeah this is awesome thanks for hopping
on zuma everyone
next
uh
what's going on with the situation on
social media we'll talk about the pros
and cons of social media
comedians used to never beef about [ __ ]
that wasn't about the stage
it's sad man
to me i mean it's sad it's unnecessary
it's [ __ ] sad
you know
we're not like
i mean it's almost like the lapd and the
sheriffs we don't need that kind of beef
in this
we all do the same [ __ ] out of the
states yeah same thing
all right all right guys
well thank you
you